childhood soon to not be put at all it's
10:00 p.m. do you know where your kids
are experts are working on a new GPS
microchip to implant in children so
parents never have to stay up late
burning again although others are
welling in concept is in its infancy it
might not be as far off as you think
using the same technology as the chips
and our smart keys and credit cards
scientists say you could easily track a
human with ID scanners placed on
doorways counters and street corners
Trish Dickerson a mother of a
three-year-old said I might go trip my
dog
why couldn't I migrate it my son Oh
Trish you microchip your dog why not
your son all right
my dog is microchipped I think that
maybe she thinks it's a slight invasion
of her privacy but I think I'm doing the
right thing but to me what's dangerous
about this is just this endless
extension of being watched all the time
between the NSA and that's all walking
around with GPS on our phones the other
day I was doing something on Gmail and
something popped up and it was like can
Google track your location all the time
which I clicked an eye on I assume they
still do it anyway like to me it's more
about the conditioning that we're gonna
have this generation of people growing
up being used to watch or you know that
the government's watching them they're
going to know that and they're gonna be
chipped I mean this is a philip k dick
novel in the making isn't it see I think
I mean I don't think it's a horrible
idea because obviously you know like
kids are not necessarily in control of
their whereabouts you know all the time
and kidnapped
okay the horrible things happen well but
I also think that there's use for that
technology like where that technology to
be developed and to be ready for
primetime I mean there is a whole
subclass of people with cognitive
disabilities that could really benefit
from that people with dementia and
Alzheimer's you know that get lost all
the time yeah so I think that that that
could potentially be useful in them and
they do have something like that like I
think for some patients they have like
bands or things like that right but with
the wristband I mean then comes the
challenge of having to take it off
charge it make sure that it's like
functional right so the microchipping
just might be a more seamless way I
don't know right I mean there is the
potential for it to end up in the hands
of people that will misuse the
technology and that's that's where it
gets dangerous right so for example you
could say all right well then we'll put
it in all the kids but we're not gonna
turn it
unless there's emergency but then do you
trust the people that they're not going
to turn it on this is like where the end
begins for me yeah and so what happens I
put it in a kit they track it Woody's
are they pop it back out
or does it stay okay that's why I think
the conditioning is the dangerous part
because they're yeah alright so they say
your parents say that it has to be till
you're 18 but then by the time you're 18
you're like that's a me I'm not going
for the thing and then just Skynet's
part of this and terminators it could
potentially be misused it could you know
open up a wormhole of just you know
misuse and I said I think of that scary
I mean I have to find my friends app on
my iPhone working for a while and I was
like using it to see where my brothers
were but after a while I deactivated
because I thought it was first of all
it's unnecessary yeah but then it could
be a bit of an invasion also is it part
of growing up that you're supposed to be
able to climb out of your bedroom window
and disappear and go to the big city and
your parents not know where you are like
I mean really isn't that an important
piece of growing up like experiencing
what freedom is absolutely yeah I mean
if this does happen you're gonna have
kids doing the classic Bourne Identity
things taking the hip out so they can go
like hang out with their buddies you
know not have mom spying on them but
it's like a black mirror episode which
I've been talking about a ton on the
show I love a black mirror so what do we
do I mean this every time I do one of
these technology things I always say
well what do we do when this stuff just
keeps coming you know we had the whole
thing with the NSA and then two months
later Apple gave us a phone that
literally took your fingerprint you know
you mean and we just they keep handing
it to us and we keep doing it I'm as
guilty as anybody but what do we do to
manage some of this stuff no it's I mean
there's no easy answer I think that you
know again I think it could be useful in
certain situations so it might be
worthwhile to see where the technology
goes but but for like every child I
think that's probably not necessary you
know a lot of times people say in the
comments that I'm like some technology
alarmist or something or a manty
technology I just think it's important
that we think about these these
questions so how do you think we can
manage sort of knowing that there's good
stuff out of all this of course and most
things that go awry usually intended to
be good at
today I think it's inevitable because of
the convenience and the life-saving
factors involved with the stuff I'm sure
that one day kids will be implanted with
chips and the government will say that
they're not spying in some future Edward
Snowden will unveil that actually the
government knows everything these kids
have been doing and so right because the
chips are connected to your optic nerve
and then they're watching the parents
through the chips you see what I'm
talking about people anyway what do you
think should we all be chipped is the
game over let us know